Activision Blizzard has a lot coming up
the company's new venture simply titled
Activision Blizzard Studios has call of
duty films and a Skylanders TV show in
the works joining Nick Van Dyke his
studio co-head is Stacey Sher who's
produced a bunch of films you probably
enjoyed share is produced over two dozen
films including Quentin Tarantino's Pulp
Fiction the hateful eight and Django
Unchained she even has an Academy Award
nomination from that last one and she's
looking forward to bringing those
talents to Activision Blizzard's
properties she said as its large and
loyal fanbase can attest Activision
Blizzard has created franchises that
means so much to audiences over the
course of 35 years I look forward to
joining Nick Bobby and the insanely
talented and forward-thinking team and
Activision Blizzard to develop an even
greater voice for these franchises but
bringing them into the world of
television and film we already know
about that Skylanders show when those
call of duty movies but we'll have to
wait and see what else Activision
Blizzard Studios cooks up whenever they
reveal the next big thing you'll
definitely hear about it from gamespot